what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
looking at the latest developments in
the attack on Titan story including the
major reveal about Mika sells true
feelings for Aaron as well as the return
of Aaron's new Titan form and man this
new form is an absolute nightmare it's
not at all what I expected it to be any
Sameh
is really going above and beyond to
entertain us and terrify us at the same
time there is so much to talk about so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the attack on titan
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going please leave a like to
let me know it really does help and if
you have to be due to animal parole or
you just haven't subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications if you don't go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell and selecting the option that says
all you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how you do works a big thank you to
all of our anime upper patrons who make
videos like this one possible I'll talk
about patreon at the end of this video
but until then please be advised that
this video will contain attack on Titan
manga spoilers we are talking about the
very latest events in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the latest crazy
installment of the story the action
picks up onboard the steamship that the
anti Eren alliance managed to capture
and escaped with during the climax of
the previous chapter and he has just
learned seemingly for the first time
that the anti Eren Alliance isn't
planning to save labarie oh because it
is already too late for lis burial as we
know their plan now is to sail to
another place a city called OD ha and
they will then attempt to save the rest
of the world by confronting Eren from
there all the Libero natives are
understandably saddened by this
including Reiner Gabi and Peake but
despite their feelings of sadness they
appear to still be on board with the
plan
Annie however isn't so understanding her
sole motivation for joining the alliance
was to save her father in Liberia and so
if it's now already too late to save him
she has no reason to be here she wants
to get off the ship
hanji tries to explain to Annie that
this fight is no longer about Marly and
parodies and it is no longer about their
own personal attachments their mission
now is to save as many innocent
civilians as they can even if they
happen to be complete strangers Magath
knew this and he was willing to
sacrifice his own life
in order to advance that goal annie is
visibly and understandably devastated by
this revelation and she poses the same
important question to Mike Asad that she
had posed before is Mikasa really
prepared to kill Aaron or if say Annie
was about to kill Aaron would Myka sigh
really be prepared to just stand back
and let it happen
overall it appears that annie is simply
at the end of her rope emotionally as
Kony and Armin entered the room and he
says that she doesn't want to fight
anymore she doesn't want to be in the
position to have to kill Mikasa Armin or
any of these guys ever again she doesn't
even want to kill Aaron but if she
continues on this mission she knows that
more death and more killing is
inevitable and you really have to feel
for Annie here even though she has done
terrible things in the past we know that
she felt genuine guilt because of these
actions we saw that with Marcos death in
particular and now after spending years
frozen inside a crystal where she was
probably reliving all her past sins over
and over again she is absolutely
exhausted emotionally annie is sick of
fighting sick of war sick of everything
pretty much her entire life was filled
with suffering and betrayal after
betrayal and at this point she doesn't
know if she has a single real friend in
the world because she has betrayed so
many people in the past for this reason
her father was pretty much the only
person in the world that she had left
and now he too would be gone
it really is tragic and I do feel
sympathy for Annie even though I would
never try to excuse the bad things that
she has done and I've mentioned this
many times in previous videos after this
moving and emotionally charged exchange
between the alliance members the focus
of the chapters shifts to Aaron to be
more specific we gain insight into his
inner thoughts and we witness a bunch of
flashbacks within flashbacks all
involving air
if you're an attack on Titan fan then
you already know that attack on Titan is
pretty much the king of flashbacks and
flashbacks with in flashbacks so I will
do my best to break all of this down in
a way that isn't too confusing
first Aaron things back to how this
whole thing started what was the true
beginning of the attack on Titan story
did the story start during Aaron's
childhood daydream or did it start with
amir fritz releasing the pigs or perhaps
it doesn't even matter where it all
started
we then jump to a moment in the past in
which Jelena is explaining zieks
euthanasia plan to Aaron she claims that
this is the only way to save the world
and for that reason they are going to
seize power on the island using Zeke's
tainted wine however after that
conversation with Jelena Aaron tells
flock that he intends to follow Zeke's
plan in appearance only but in reality
Aaron will be plotting his own counter
plan so it turns out that Aaron really
did confide in flock about the real plan
when flock first claimed that that
happened I honestly thought that he was
potentially just lying to get all the
jaegers to support him and think that
Aaron trusts him but it turns out the
flock wasn't lying so there you have it
he wasn't just an Aaron fanboy he really
was part of the plan we then
transitioned into another flashback this
time a conversation between Aaron and
Queen historia they are discussing the
plans of the military police and how to
potentially counter these plans and his
story express his gratitude for Aaron
and the other Scouts standing up for her
and protecting her back when the secret
of the basement was first revealed Aaron
then reveals his ultimate plan to
historia the same plan that he had
revealed to flock he intends to initiate
the rumbling and destroy everyone
outside of the island in order to
protect the island itself historia is
instantly opposed to this plan and she
says that even though bad people exist
outside of the island most of the people
out there are innocent civilians if they
follow this plan Dan Aaron just outlined
these innocent people would be killed
out of nowhere without even knowing why
or what they did to deserve this and
ironically this would be exactly like
Aaron's own mother when she was killed
by Titans so many years
oh but Erin reminds historia how much
the outside world hates the audience and
how no matter what the audience try the
people the outside world will continue
to attack parodies until every last
resident of the island is dead
Erin has come to believe that the only
way to end the cycle of death suffering
and revenge that humans have been
inflicting on each other for millennia
is to destroy the outside world
completely including human civilization
itself
only then will humanity have a chance
for a fresh start and perhaps this time
they won't repeat the same mistakes
maybe Erin plans to manipulate the
memories of all of the survivors so that
they don't even know the meaning of war
and revenge perhaps he can make them
think that human nature is inherently
peaceful in the hopes that just
believing this will make it a reality
but of course even if Erin does this
there is no guarantee that humanity
won't continue to fight itself if you
believe that humans are inherently
violent by Nature
then no amount of master planning and
mind manipulation can stop them from
turning violent again in the future Erin
also explains to historian that if they
leave things as they are the current
government and parodies which is the
priya giris regime as this conversation
is taking place before the Jaeger as'
took over will try to force historian to
have children so that they can keep
enforcing the old system of fritzsche
children being forced to eat their
parents in order to continue the line of
the founding Titan Erin refuses to let
this happen to historian and he feels
that the only way to break this vicious
cycle is to initiate the rumbling once
and for all
historian says that she could never live
with herself if she didn't try to stop
Erin from killing all these innocent
people but Erin says that he can just
manipulate her memories so that she
doesn't have to live with the guilt in
the final exchange between Aaron and
história historia asks him what would
you think about me having a child and as
we know eventually historian does become
pregnant allegedly by some random stable
boy or farm boy or something but after
this very personal exchange between her
and Erin I am not so sure did Erin
actually father historias child after
this conversation took place and if so
why why is it so important for historian
to have a child now if Erin plans on
destroying the current system and all of
human civilization outside the island
which would
theoretically mean that the fritz family
founding titan cycle doesn't need to
continue
why does historian need a child now if
Aaron says that he doesn't want her to
be forced to have children definitely
let me know what you think down in the
comments below we then get yet another
flashback this time we get a glimpse of
Zeke and Aaron talking back in the
barrio during Aaron's infiltration of
the internment Zone and during this
conversation
Zeke specifically says that he doesn't
think that members of the Ackermann clan
have some sort of natural compulsion to
protect the person they are loyal to in
fact Zeke explicitly says that he thinks
Mikasa is so kind to Aaron because she
genuinely likes him and it's not because
she's an acraman and feel some sort of
unnatural instinct or urge to protect
him at all cost as we know this is the
exact opposite of what Aaron told me
Cass up back when he wanted to keep her
away from him and his plans he had told
her that she only cares about him
because of her Ackerman instinct not
because she actually cares about him on
a personal level it now seems that this
was just a blatant lie by Aaron he
probably wanted to protect Mikasa from
Zeke and from the outcome of his own
apocalyptic plan so he tried to convince
mica so that her love for him was a lie
so she would just move on and not get
hurt later but that's just my own
speculation at this point based on the
information that we have so far
Aaron ultimately tells Zeke that he has
only four years to live anyway so he's
not worried about himself he wants to
find a way to protect his loved ones so
that they could live full and happy
lives after he is gone but this has
really got me thinking if this is
Aaron's goal then how is he ultimately
going to achieve it and I don't mean
this in terms of what he told Zeke or
his story or anyone else but in terms of
what he ultimately plans to actually do
will he really destroy the entire
outside world or does he have some other
plan that no one knows about is he going
to pull Allah loose is he going to send
a message to the world by destroying a
part of it but then stopping short of
killing everyone or is he going to do
something else altogether right now it
definitely seems like Aaron really does
intend to destroy all human civilization
outside of the island of parodies but we
might still be surprised what he
ultimately does after all Issei Yama
loves misdirection
and shocking twists back into present
time we finally see what Godzilla Aaron
and those millions of Titans are
currently up to a massive fleet of
battleships referred to as the global
Allied fleet has amassed on the shores
of the continent this is the fleet that
was going to attack parodies with the
intention of destroying all the LD ins
on the island all the biggest ships
cannons and weapons of all sorts in the
world have been gathered here in one
place in an attempt to stop the rumbling
but I have to say that I highly doubt
that this gathering of forces started
after the rumbling itself it would have
taken months for them to amass this
fleet and the rumbling only began very
recently so the truth is that while they
might be trying to stop the rumbling now
this fleet was initially mobilized in
order to attack the island of parodies
and its people
this only underscores Aaron's point that
the outside world was determined to
destroy the Islanders and it further
emphasizes why he feels that he has to
do what he is doing right now it is
definitely pretty convenient for Aaron
that the deadliest weapons in the world
have all been amassed right here this
means that Aaron will be able to destroy
all of these weapons in one fell swoop
before human starts leveling cities and
other things on the continent so who
knows maybe Aaron really will stop after
sending a strong message by destroying
the entire global Allied fleet but we'll
have to wait and see the Allied fleet
unleashes countless cannon shells at the
wall Titans who are approaching the
continent but it's no use the wall
Titans are even capable of swimming
underwater so they are able to avoid
most of the cannons while destroying the
ships that are firing upon them I never
thought about this idea of titans being
able to swim I just kind of imagined
them walking on the bottom of the ocean
but it makes sense as we know the bodies
of titans are massive but on a
pound-for-pound basis they are much
lighter than the bodies of a normal
human so in that sense it makes sense
that they would be able to float in
large bodies of water and even swim at
any rate the fleet is absolutely
demolished and the Titans reach the
shore of the continent without much
trouble the Marlins are continuing to
fire their cannons from the shore but a
man
they realize that there isn't much they
can do and they begin to retreat the
soldiers also spot Aaron in the distance
and his absolutely monstrous new attack
Titan form Aaron's new Titan towers over
the already massive wall Titans and we
finally get to see Aaron's new Titan
form in greater detail and let me tell
you it is freaking terrifying this is
the stuff of nightmares
oh dude I'd assumed that Aaron's new
Titan would look like a giant dinosaur
because of the shape of its massive
spine and I'd refer to it as Godzilla
Titan but in reality this monstrosity
looks completely different from anything
that I had imagined the new Eren Titan
looks like a gigantic spider made of
bones and hanging from the gigantic bony
spider like body is an additional
upside-down skeleton torso the head of
this upside-down skeleton torso looks
like Aaron's attack Titan but much
creepier this Titan reminds me of the
girl from The Exorcist if she became a
Titan it's just so freakin creepy and
messed up I have no idea how practical
this Titan form is or how it is even
moving but it is indeed advancing
towards the shoreline and the Marlin
soldiers are absolutely terrified and so
are the rest of us we then see a
flashback of Aaron as a child watching
us his own mother is devoured by the
smiling Titan and this is juxtaposed to
the present situation a situation in
which a monstrous Eren is the one
leading an army of titans to destroy
humanity I talk about this a lot in my
attack on Titan videos but it is just so
crazy to me that Aaron went from vowing
to destroy all the Titans in order to
save humanity to now using the Titans to
destroy humanity this is just amazing
and haunting character development aaron
has done a complete 180
in terms of his current goals and
motivations compared to his initial
goals and motivations and yet within the
context of the story it makes sense we
know exactly why Aaron changed his mind
so drastically it makes perfect sense in
the context of that world which makes it
such a good story overall and that is
how this insane horrifying an incredible
chapter
I've been saying for months that I want
to see Aaron's new Titan form in greater
detail and I kept complaining about he
say I'm teasing us but now that I've
actually seen Aaron's new Titan form I
honestly don't know how to feel about it
this is not what I was expecting at all
that said I am really looking forward to
the next chapter and I am extremely
curious to see how this new Titan even
works and what abilities it possesses
let me know what you guys think
do you like Aaron's new form or did you
have nightmares about it like I did also
what do you think Aaron will end up
doing is he really going to go through
with his plan to destroy human
civilization will he perhaps stop after
obliterating the global fleet and
sending a strong message will he pull a
Lelouch or some other option also do you
think that this crazy new heir and Titan
form can even be stopped
don't be shy share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more videos like
it please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar or maybe you just
haven't subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thanks to all of our the one tier
patrons to want to rise above all other
clans including Ingrid ah a Lola Madame
the world Steelers acquired respect but
they have fun Jonathan King Brandon
Avila's Papa Smurf the school bus King
riser emperor otaku Ricardo Martinez
Thomas Jones Kinmen Oh Michael Hyde and
Jade and the vector and I can't forget
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatole Kazansky on hell cruise
critics beep Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alicia octor Jessica Kayla Fond
Kinoko me and water Bonnie parks Zoe
arch 12 rothwyn de hora Kraken our
Elle's and deadly Saint if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our peach and exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]